Okay. Ready? Yeah. Hey, I'm Jetta. Boom, rod. And I remember Colbert.
This is Radiolab, our fun drive addition, when we're trying to prevail upon you,
give you all the reasons we can think of to support public radio and radio lab
in particular. You know what Robert, why,
why should we even say anything when I think it's more powerful when somebody
who uses radio lab who uses public radio can say it for us. Well,
you have someone in mind. I do. I have a story here that came into our inbox.
This is a true story where public radio, you ready for this? Okay.
Literally saved a boy's life. What? All right, so I'm exaggerating a little,
but it helped out in a pretty dire situation. And if saving lives,
healing wounds doesn't make you want to support this service, then well,
frankly I don't know what will.
So anyhow, um, the woman who wrote,
we're just going to call her right now. Her name is Jennifer Bab and how,
how would we be spelling [inaudible]
bad baptism. Yes sir.
Jennifer Bab as MBA. Yes.
That will be via the B.
Yup. And it involves her and
her son. Like
hello. Hi, is this Jennifer? Yes. Hey,
this is Jad and this is Robert here on the other microphone. Hi Guys.
Nice to meet you. Nice to meet you telephonically. Now Jennifer,
I understand you have a, you have a son, right?
Yes, I have two children you might send is my oldest. He's seven and a half lake
blink. And so can you set the scene for the story you're gonna tell it?
Well, let's see. So Blake, um, he says when he grows up,
he's going to be an inventor.
What do you like to build most of all is airplane airplanes and helicopters.
Okay. So the first one, the belt were just, you know,
he'd take a couple of pieces of Tupperware and lay them out on the floor in the
shape of the plane.
But lately he's been trying to build planes that actually fly.
So he made this airplane.
He's sitting next to me now and he's telling me it's more like a helicopter.
It's okay.
40 bucks cut out too long.
Propeller blades that he duct taped together in the shape of an egg.
And the propeller, I have to say the propeller is really cool.
The propeller actually flies.
So we have kind of a balcony on our house and he stood up on the balcony and
like flung it off and then hovered in there
really? Oh Wow. Moment
before falling to the ground.
Okay. So, so you, you, you've done a bunch of tests with this propeller,
you see that it can fly and then I'm assuming at a certain point, um,
he takes it to the next step.
Yeah.
So He's been learning about electricity and about motors and things and he's got
a couple of toys that have motors on them.
So He's been trying to build an airplane that'll hook up to the motor and he
tried to attach his pillar and it just fell over.
Yeah. See the motor wasn't powerful enough.
Right.
And so there's only one thing that we've got that strong enough to power a
propellor of this size and IP human beings.
Oh yes.
So what he did was, since the motor didn't work,
he made out of duct tape a harness system so that he could kind of climb inside
the harness and hold on to the propeller.
And he's, is he going to twist the propellors himself while he's flying?
Exactly. Grabbed my do it with his hands in this kinda like spin to make it fly.
And so, you know, we have this rock wall that's about, I dunno,
three feet high. And so he climbed up on the rock wall
and jumped and he said, you have retraced back.
Really? He felt it. He felt that.
So all kind of weird.
Hi. Hi Blake. Hi. So you felt like, uh,
so where did you jump from? You jumped from the wall.
Hello? Hello
Blake, are you there? Blake is, um, he's not a really big talker.
And did you mom know any of this was happening at this point? Yeah,
I made a movie of it.
So you are aware of his experiments in flight?
Yeah, well, it's fascinating to watch, you know, to see how his mind works.
He's learning. Like I said, you know, every time, every iteration,
you learn something from the weight of one before fail.
Whoa.
So that was, um, that was in the evening.
That was like eight o'clock at night and the next day he's was a Saturday or
Sunday and he's fussing around in the garage. And, um,
my husband and I were in the kitchen talking about whatever.
And Blake comes walking past with his harness system on and he walks through the
doors to go into the backyard.
Just walks right through, right? There's something slightly Calvin and Hobbes,
he about this pill for whatever reason,
not arouse our suspicion as it should have, you know,
I don't know what we were talking about. And then, you know, two,
three minutes later we hear the cry.
[inaudible]
you know, the kind of cry that's not,
I'm scared or wham hungry. It's the cry. That means I'm hurt.
Now just to jump in here.
Jennifer Warren's outside to the backyard where there's this maple tree and she
looks up and she sees her son
weakly entangled in the tree,
look to her,
like he'd climbed up to the top branch with the harness of Dumont and then
jumped and got twisted and he was really, really bloody.
He had scraped the whole back of his leg,
this big like foot long gash and are just like, oh my God. Oh my God.
Just bleeding all down his leg. And,
and how my husband had to like push him up so that I could untangle the,
like ropey bits of the duct tape harness system to get him off and pull him
down. So I, you know,
carried him through through the kitchen and put 'em on the couch in the living
room
and she says she tried to turn him over so she could get a look at the cut.
But he kept squirming and wouldn't let her see it.
And that was the moment it occurred to me to put on radio lab.
Oh,
capture his imagination. So he buys,
still forget that his leg hurt him and then I could look at it while he was
distracted.
What gave you that idea?
I don't know. That iPod was kind of sitting there and I was like, okay,
I'll put on Radiolab and he can listen to the bit about parasites.
So when you press go or, or begin on your, on your iPod, what happened?
Oh, he was instantly fascinated. He listened to the whole entire podcast,
the whole 45 minutes or whatever it is and yeah, and I was able,
I got his, uh, wound cleaned off to get a child like that to stop moving,
to stop twitching in some degree. Like you should see him right now.
He's sitting here like tapping his feet and playing with this spork. Um,
and you had his attention from the first moment,
but it goes beyond that. According to Jennifer,
after she'd been playing him the show for a few minutes,
she paused it just shortly after a segment we made about a parasitic wasp.
What it does is it flies around and it looks for a cockroach.
That's the one. And she asked him, did you understand any of that?
And he repeated it back to me. Yeah.
Almost word for word. Maybe we should put Blake on. Yeah.
Okay. Let me go get them. They are ready to talk to you.
Hi.
Hi. So we want to hear like what can you remember about the radio show?
The one that parishes was um,
the parish wast is flying around.
Then it finds cockroach
that finds that cockroach.
They tumbled back and forth around.
Patricia Gwas mentioned this, stab it in the stomach, right in the belly,
the cockroach, which is for a second.
And then it this fault go and it's stings it.
The Stinger actually started threads its way
to a particular spot in the brain
in a way they can control the clock colors.
This stands up.
And so now the hall sits by the end,
the cockroaches contento
and start pulling out, down, down,
down, down.
He lays eggs and say the cockroach. And then the eggs hatch.
You remember the entire story? Yes. Jennifer too is flabbergasted.
And she says she turned to him and was like, wow, Blake, what?
Excellent listening comprehension. You have, you do understand what you hear.
And he said yes,
but I don't understand when people are talking to me.
You mean like he doesn't understand that when people talk at him or lecture him?
Yeah,
like when I'm in trouble I never understand what you're talking about.
And so I did have the thought that if only I had the means I could record some
of my lectures so that I could play them back.
You know with the right sound effects,
that's the baby you would have that the same like it tends to be of listening to
what I was trying to say. Those two mothers everywhere,
mothers across America,
we were paying millions of dollars for these lectures.
Which brings me to a really quick pitch.
Public radio is all about making stories stick.
That's what we try and do at radio lab and all the shows. Try and do,
do you have um, lecturers off the top of your head?
Because if you give them to us we could give them back to you.
And in that radio lab five version.
See there, I guess there is, there's one thing, and this is, you know,
this kind of gets at the whole climbing up into a tree with propellers.
Like you have to think things all the way through to the end.
Hmm. Jennifer says she said that to Blake millions of times.
She's not sure if it ever gets through
things through to the end.
So we thought we would try and give her a new spin on it.
I don't know if this is going to work, but hey, let's give it a shot.
Here is our, uh, attempt to make a sticky lecture for Blake.
Have to think things all the way through
[inaudible]
thing all the way. Thanks. Thanks. Thanks.
Thanks all the way through.
I think saying all the way,
all the way,
like what your mom is saying is that when you want to have an adventure or
prevent something,
don't just think about the beginning of it or what you think might happen in the
middle, in your mind. Take it all the way through.
You know, it's okay to test your theories. You know,
I encourage experimentation. The only way you're
going to learn is if you fail.
She's not just saying that. I mean, Take Thomas Edison, the king inventor,
he tried to invent a battery and he failed 10,000 times,
but he needed to think about,
so you have to kind of consider what kind of the best outcome,
the worst outcome, and imagine that both of those things have happened.
Like imagine the scenario in your mind and what you include.
Okay, let's do that. Scenario one, you're in the tree, this is the good one.
And you see
being on the blade round, round,
round and round and round and round and round in.
It works.
You're, you're flying all through the neighborhood.
So here's the question. You've got to answer. What happens next?
What he hasn't thought is, for example, how is he going to land?
Hmm. So you gotta take it all the way through to the landing part.
Now let's play out the other scenario. The one where things don't go well.
Let's say you jump out of the tree and you crash and you really hurt yourself.
Well think of how sad your mom would be and your dad
and your sister
cases where you make up a little movie in your head and you play it all the way
through and hopefully the good one will happen, the best outcome.
But just in case you'll now be prepared
so that you can mitigate the effects. Worst outcome.
And I probably wouldn't say mitigate to my child,
so we're going to do something with this lecture and send it to you.
Uh Huh.
No, seriously. Well thanks you guys. I'll talk to you. Yes.
And we have no absolutely no connection to any kind of further experimentation
of this kind of love yourself and responsibility on his own.
Okay. Alright. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Right, bye.
[inaudible]
no, I don't exactly know what to say here,
but there is something about this story that just kind of like gets to the whole
point of why we do this. Yeah.
And here you've got this kid who's obviously in a lot of pain,
and he just sits still and listens to a story about parasites.
You know what we're trying to do here is tell stories that move you.